[Music]
by the way this was on purpose correct
no no and in fact I was just telling his
mother that I nearly texted her this
morning because I got dressed and I
thought he could totally wear this I was
just so happy to see him because he's
been in New York
oh don't roll your eyes you love that
city we went to seashell so what was
that like going to see Broadway with him
and vice versa
audience our first I have never been you
had so many more people recognized you
in the theater they recognized me they
loved you there that is true and it's
not just because you wore tap shoes and
they could hear you coming but I'm a
little honored to be here today with you
because I feel like you only deal with
the heavy hitters so is that like in
your contracts I only work with Oscar
winners and big time actors yeah it's
actually on it's not actually really
really really really really really
really lucky so deserved why would you
entertain evil thoughts I don't think
this part applies to me I'm only nine
years old most evil doesn't start till
puberty where did you find him on tape
he taped himself Chuck and Steve wrote
this ridiculously long complicated
monologue which is not in the script
Ian's was mind blowing in some ways
it's it's true there was a naturalness
with it and a spirit with it and an
understanding of what you were saying
when we get home I'm gonna kick your
little balls
you can't down descended yet mom what
when try be expecting my testicles as
you've been having a blast already I'm
gonna let you answer your own question
again good
am I asking dumb questions no no ever no
you are having fun and it's been really
inspirational to watch I mean there's
just a way in which he's tackling all of
this that is such fun and such joy of
the process well now are you just you're
a reminder to I think anybody who's been
doing it a while to remember how much
fun it is
[Music]